now we've heard a lot about surging
prices in this country now the federal
reserve is getting ready to take action
it's likely to mean higher interest
rates for tens of millions of americans
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger is here to tell us what we
need to know so what does this mean for
consumers well essentially what the fed
is doing is it is taking its foot off
the accelerator of a pretty hot economy
and this has different ramifications but
it really impacts all of us so if you're
a saver when the fed starts raising
interest rates next year they'll
probably be three quarter point
increases if you're a saver you're
psyched you're like oh my god i'm get
finally getting some more money on my
savings if you're a borrower you're not
so happy credit cards auto loans maybe
you're a small business those costs
could start to rise so it's going to
impact everyone so how does this impact
the housing market and mortgages so
interesting because with housing it's
not keyed to the rate that the fed
controls it keys off of a longer term
mortgage rate so interest rate so
mortgage might they might see start to
drift higher that shouldn't really harm
the housing market it actually might be
a little bit welcome relief to cool that
housing market off a little bit but if
you have a home equity line of credit or
a variable loan that could cost you more
come next year so if interest rates are
expected to rise what can consumers do
well obviously this is advice that
really is probably pretty much obvious
for most people which is if you have a
variable rate loan you want to start
paying it down as quickly as you can a
lot of people can't afford to do that i
would say also if you're thinking about
a refinance i might try to lock that in
right now one thing i really want to
warn about please don't tinker with your
portfolio a lot of people were shocked
to say hey interest rates are going up
why the stock market go up well that's
because the market participants actually
expected it so no tinkering if possible
that's great advice i love it when you
come in and break it all down like
cardboard boxes on recycling day hey
thank you very much i like that best all
right